josiah gray who will make his first ever
start for the washington nationals gray
part of the hall the nationals got last
week at the trade deadline now gene
segura batting second in the order and
the wine of the pitch swinging a bit
struck him out fastball up and away
came with a heat challenged segura and
he strikes out swinging for out number
two
ranger suarez well he's been serving as
the phillies closer most recently ranger
returning to his roots tonight as a
member of the starting rotation soto
batting 299 with 18 home runs
three and two
and a cult strike three right at the
knees
95
and so far so good for ranger suarez
one two three go the nationals we'll go
to the second
so gene seguro will get a chance first
and third here's the o2
swinging a high drive to center field
robles turns all the way around now he
finds the ball moving in and to his left
and he makes the catch
so here is gregorius who popped up on
the infield his first time up so it was
first and second no outs it's now first
and third two outs
and the national shift on the right side
leaving key boom on the left
the set for gray his first pitch
is numbed off the end of the bat third
base side kibum cuts it off to his left
fires to first in the inning over
jojo gray with a fist pump as he departs
the mound he works out of his first big
time jam first and second no outs the
phillies do not score
hector only helps the world
when he's at the plate
and he's going to get a chance to bat at
some point
trying to figure out how to get the
other end other end
oh no well double did have a base hit
his first at-bat
and now the 3-2 to odouble
now duval hits one of the air in a deep
right center field it is gone
a solo home run for herrera it's his
seventh of the year
he has only 11 hits since the first of
july but you wouldn't know it by that
swing right there it's one nothing
phillies
hectornaris the batter here's the wide
of the o2
and that one's in there strength recall
that will bring up bryce harper
is flying to the wall in left field of
the first inning and he drew a four
pitch walk
leading off the fourth inning
now gray sets
and the pitch swinging the ground ball
right side keyboard the third baseman to
the right side cutting it off and the
throw to bell in time to retire the side
well the final pitching line
on jojo gray is five innings a run four
hit struck out two keyboard grabbed it
out to third his first time
lifts this one in the air toward right
center field harper and sigoura and it's
segora who makes the catch he rips it
right out of the air and when they
traded daniel hudson to san diego the
other day we heard about this big
right-hander who can bring it the gnats
we're getting six seven 223
23 year old mason thompson and they are
loaded up
maurice hoskins will come to the plate
the o2 pitch swinging a miss he struck
him out 96 with an inside fastball and
the side retired and the phillies leave
the bases loaded stevenson
seven pinch hits this year and 23 at
bats
he launches one to right
c
u
leader
back wall the bullpen
and this one's tied
andrew stevenson's second pinch hit home
run of the season
his third overall
and the nationals are even on one big
swing the nationals won in the phillies
one
and adrian sanchez will come to the
plate
that's a beauty
boom makes a nice play wow what a play
that was bear hands it and throws all in
one motion
and there are two outs you kidding me
it's two runners on and two outs
josh bell is the batter
in a tie game bottom of the sixth inning
two and two to josh bell
the pitch
and a fastball on the inside corner
strike three calls
the nationals do tie it up on the home
run by stevenson
miller looking at his strikeout rate 69
and 192 at bats so one out of every
three
that one gets away and here comes segora
with the go-ahead run
[Applause]
he'll get the pop-up
the runner is harper
it's hernandez bryce coming throw coming
and
they got him
hernandez guns down bryce harper going
in with a head first dive for his first
outfield assist of the year and so
garcia will come up here and we would
guess to try to bunt the runners over
little tapper in front of the plate it's
a swinging bunt jt throws to third what
a play by boom the
an outstanding play by alec balm to pick
it on the backhand with jt taking a
chance to go to third
two five on the put out bases loaded
archie bradley will be the pitcher
ryan zimmerman is one for four against
him
left side bishop
ki boom scores here comes garcia
employee number 11
does it again
but now victor robles the batter
trey turner had a 360 batting average or
has a 360 batting average against
fastballs
bouncer over to short there's one
and two
a six four three double play
[Applause]
it is a shame they didn't get that one
batter
the national score two to take the lead
here's oduba herrera
a single to right center in the third he
homered leading off the top of the fifth
against jojo gray the starter
and then drew a walk in the sixth inning
so they haven't gotten him out yet
swinging a ground ball in hard right
side diving stop by the second baseman
sanchez from a knee the throw to first
for the out retires the side
adrian sanchez with a diving stop on a
one hop liner uh-oh what is that
it's a mantis praying for a rally that's
an alien
it's from like men in black right that
thing is going to erase your mind as you
know it's right
along for the ride
and i can't call it a rally play praying
mantis or alien or whatever the heck i
called it before but i've never seen
anything like that you come to the
ballpark and watch a baseball game you
never know what you're going to see
including a huge
insect attacking victor robles in center
field
manchester's still perched
this is going to go viral by the way
wander suarrow takes over for the
nationals
and he'll face gene segora
out toward right field toward the alley
and right center field it's going to
split the gap in one hop the wall teres
will score jankowski's being held at
third it's an rbi double tied up at
three still nobody out here in the top
of the ninth inning
so the bases are loaded for jt
and he lines it into left field of base
hit one ruddle score rounding third
heading for alma segura he's gonna score
and the phillies not only take the lead
they add on another one it's five to
three a big base hit for jt real muto
here at the top of the ninth bidding
what does he not see i mean juan soto
went over to him during the pitching
change and was talking to apparently he
knows it's there now oh yeah
and it brings alec balm up
okay that's kind of funny that's very
funny
and boom rips that one to left center
field of base hit
it's easily going to score bryce harper
real muto holds up at third an rbi for
baum that's his second hit of the night
they do add another one it's now a 6-3
ball game and now didi's the eighth man
to bat in this inning
ground ball to right side
they throw to first for one and now bell
gets bomb in a rundown good job
jt does score though the run counts well
done alec bone alec took a look at it to
make sure it's now 7-3 in favor of the
fills so here's carter keeble
look at this thing fly
see
you
later
carter keyboard first of the year third
big league homer
hello
it's seven to five and nobody out
bang
zoom goes carter kibum
gerardo
swag and a miss and a high fastball when
the ball game is over
the phillies pull to within two and a
half games of the new york mets of the
division
you